Speaker 1: I want to look at a few clips from
an event that took place in South Carolina
over the weekend. The event is called Vision
24, the National Conservative Forum. A couple
of interesting speakers there. We will
get to Nikki Haley, who spoke there. But
I want to start with Tulsi Gabbard now. Tulsi
Gabbard is someone who started as a Democratic
congresswoman who ran for president back in
2020. Extraordinarily transparent grifter,
which unfortunately some in my audience and
in concert in left wing media fell for hook,
line and sinker. But she is no longer a Democrat
and she's now promotes anti-vax and she promotes
all sorts of crazy stuff. The grift is up,
except it kind of has only just started because
everything Tulsi is doing is her most direct
path to making money. And I'll explain that
in a moment. But Tulsi Gabbard spoke at this
conservative forum, and I have to tell you,
she is truly a sick person in this first clip.
Tulsi revives the completely debunked notion
of Democrats supporting abortion after birth,
or, as you and I might call it, the killing of
children. This is, of course, not true. It's been
widely debunked. Let's look at what Tulsi now has
the audacity to say. Remember, this was the last
real liberal, according to someone on the left.
Speaker 2: Celebrate. I couldn't believe it when
I saw it in this last State of the Union speech.
How many members of Congress are walking around
with a big abortion pin on their suit jacket?
Speaker 1: Right. Incredible that they feel a
need to support that, to show that they support
women's rights, to make medical decisions in the
context of a Supreme Court and a Republican Party
that is hell bent on attacking that. Right. But
shocking that Democrats would show that, hey,
we support women's rights.
Speaker 2:
Not just advocating for, but celebrating
abortion on demand, on demand without exception,
all the way up until birth or even after
birth, normalizing infanticide. We've seen
this in places like New York and other states.
Speaker 1: What? So this this is straight up
untrue. So let's break it down into two
parts. Until birth and then after birth,
even until birth is very deceptive. And I'll
explain to you why. So-called late term abortions.
Right. The kind that would need to be approved
under special circumstances in many state laws are
extraordinarily rare. Republicans continue doing
this thing where they love to pretend you can be,
you know, 37 and a half weeks pregnant
and show up and say, you know what,
I'd like to end the pregnancy. OB-GYNs have
extensively testified under oath that it
doesn't happen and that if it did, it wouldn't
be something that 99.9% of OB-GYNs would even
do. These are extremely rare situations that in
almost every case relate to extreme circumstances,
things that are discovered about the health of
the fetus or the or the health of the mother.
It is insanely rare. Under 1% of abortions are
performed after 21 weeks, never mind 32 weeks,
34 weeks. The way these people
want to talk about insanely rare
and the idea of a you know what? My due
dates next week. I think I want an abortion
almost imaginary beyond that this entire after
birth abortion. I mean just it's completely flat
fabricated. And Tulsi, of all people, is now
going with it. Just disgusting person, truly
disgusting person that she has debased herself in
this way. Then she does the elitist cabal stuff.
She's buying into that as well.
Speaker 2:
When you look at the Democratic Party of today,
it is a party that is controlled by this elitist
cabal of warmongers that has been and continues
to be led by the queen of warmongers herself,
Hillary Clinton.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: It's true.
Speaker 1: The applause delayed there. People
are like, wait, Hillary, Hillary, the warmonger?
Speaker 2: What and who the when you look at their
policies, they are driven by this
motivation of cowardly wokeness.
Speaker 1: They are such cowards and bloodthirsty
warmongers, but they're they're cowards. And
therefore it doesn't make sense. Now, why is she
doing this? I hate to say that it's this simple,
but I. I believe this is this is probably it. This
is how she maximizes her income. Okay. She's got a
podcast and she gets paid to speak and she's a Fox
News contributor. Tulsi Gabbard made, I believe
at the time that she was a member of Congress. I
think the salary was 174,000 a year. She did this
run for president total failure. She got, what,
1% of the vote? Zero. I don't even she was polling
one or 2%. And I don't know that anybody voted for
her. Totally failed. Not remotely a progressive
platform in reality. So now she's done the
thing where she becomes right wing. The
left left me. The Democratic Party has failed
me. Believe that I'm not alone. So that's an
appealing product and that's what it is. It's a
product. The former left winger who, by the way,
wasn't really left. So she starts doing speaking
gigs for what? You know, based on her notoriety.
This is a very rough guess, but she
could probably get between 12 and
25,000 per speaking gig if she has a good
speaking agent on the podcast. You know,
it doesn't seem like a huge podcast, but it might
net her like low six figures and then she's a Fox
News contributor, probably also like a low six
figure deal. So that's the grift. She and these
are super rough estimates. She's probably making
half a million bucks a year. It might be 250,
it might be 600 or 650. Something like this is
the most lucrative way to productize herself,
to turn herself into the commodity of the former
Democrat who's willing to go and talk about how
vaccines are bad and trans is bad and abortion
is bad, and on and on and on. If she remains a
Democrat, no one listens to her podcast. It's not
a good podcast. If she's a Democrat, she doesn't
get any of these speaking gigs because the right
is much more interested in funding. Oh, the former
Democrat. And if she's a Democrat, she almost
certainly doesn't get the Fox News contributor.
Seven But when I say if she's a Democrat, I mean
if she continues to be at least claiming to be
on the left, she could have, you know, nominally
remained a Democrat and done basically the same
stuff. So it's it's the grift and this is what
you'll see is doing. And to the extent that she's
like what's best for myself personally, I get it.
It's just pretty disgustingly overtly a grift. And
this is where we end up towards is saying
Democrats want to do abortion after birth.